wait did this American doctor just admit
to murdering people yes he did this
guy's name is Cornelius Rhodes he was
sent to San Juan by the Rockefeller
Institute in the 30s to work on anemia
but while he was there he writes a
letter and admits to killing eight of
his patients and transplanting cancer
into even more in the letter he says
that Puerto Rico's population needed to
be exterminated and that he was going to
do it someone working at the hospital
finds the letter but it's kind of
written off as a joke so he doesn't get
prosecuted or even get fired instead he
joins the Army's chemical warfare unit
and tests poisonous gas on people then
like none of it happened he literally
goes on to become the director of a
prestigious cancer center and eventually
makes it on the front cover of Time
Magazine a fancy award was even named
after him and it's given out by the
American associate for cancer research
for over 20 years and yes he went on to
do all of this amazing work for cancer
treatment which I think people use to
justify the fact that he was a racist
person wanting to commit genocide
against the people of Puerto Rico